GORDON RAMSEY (VOICEOVER):
With enough salmon
for the final cook,
I'm off to meet
a guy who's been innovative with
Iceland's geothermal energy.
I'm told he has a very
unusual way of baking bread.
Siggi.
Hey.
How are you, captain?
Very good.
Good to see you, man.
Good to see you.
Oh, boy.
Are you good?
Yeah, very good.
That is a very firm handshake.
Yeah, good grip.
Good grip.
What's going on here?
I want to show you
a real rye bread.
Right, a rye bread?
Yeah.
I mean, my gran
makes rye bread.
So what's your secret
about this one?
I can promise you she never
made rye bread like this.
We got here I have
4 cups of rye.
Yep.
And 2 cups of flour--
Right
In the same bowl.
How old is this recipe?
Is it a recipe from the
family, traditions or--
Yeah, it is, late
1800s early 1900s.
Yeah.
Good.
Yes, then you put on a glove.
The glove?
Yeah, one glove.
Little butter.
You got a problem?
Bend over.
Take a little butter.
Yes.
And you--
Gotcha.
All of this and--
All of it?
Yep.
And that's it?
We don't leave it to prove
for 10 minutes or anything?
No?
No.
So where are we going
to bake this thing?
The ground is
boiling underneath us.
Really?
It's a very active
hot spring area.
Right here in this village
we have a huge hot spring,
and we used to heat
up the village.
All from these
hot springs here?
The geothermal literally
takes care of all the heating?
Absolutely, Yeah.
Wow, gotcha.
Is that enough?
That's enough.
All right.
So where's the oven?
Right over there.
We have to do a little work.
GORDON RAMSEY (VOICEOVER):
And by work, he
means digging my
own oven and burning
volcanic Earth with a shovel.
And by we, he means me.
You used a shovel before?
I have definitely
used a shovel.
How far down we going?
Farther.
Do you feel that heat?
And more.
It's OK.
We have the sun for 24 hours.
So we have plenty of time.
This is true.
The heat in here is insane.
How big a hole do you want?
Until we see a good bubble.
[bleep] now, Siggi.
Yeah, you hit the
spot right here.
Right, you sound like my wife.
[laughing]
Keep shoveling.
More to the right.
More To the right.
OK, Siggi.
You don't have to
get vicious on me.
SIGGI: That's perfect.
Put the pot now on
top of the bubbles.
Exactly, yes.
Really?
Yeah.
OK.
GORDON RAMSEY: Yes, it's hot.
SIGGI: It looks pretty good.
GORDON RAMSEY: And
bubbling away like mad.
SIGGI: Yeah.
GORDON RAMSEY: But the
temperature that's hot.
It's really hot.
SIGGI: Yeah, it's above
boiling temperature.
GORDON RAMSEY: That water
when you get down, trust me,
is piping hot.
What a magical way of cooking.
No gas, no electric,
just a beautiful spring.
You're almost done.
Now we put the
rock on top of it.
We want to market, you know.
Beautiful.
Seriously?
Now, how long is that
going to take to cook?
24 hours.
Siggi, I have not
got 24 hours, trust me.
I already baked one.
So why didn't we just
go straight to that one?
You made me dig that hole.
Well, I mean, you don't
want to miss all the fun.
This is it.
OK, moment of truth.
GORDON RAMSEY: - And
this one in 24 hours ago?
SIGGI: Yeah, can you hear it?
GORDON RAMSEY: I can hear it.
That's incredible.
Listen to that bubbling.
SIGGI: Yeah, yeah.
GORDON RAMSEY: That is insane.
SIGGI: Put it over here.
GORDON RAMSEY: Siggi.
SIGGI: It's a beauty.
GORDON RAMSEY: Honestly,
you're not just a pretty face.
[laughing]
That looks beautiful.
That smells delicious.
Yeah, it does.
Look at the color of it.
All from in there.
Ready?
Yeah.
[clanging]
GORDON RAMSEY: Oh.
My God.
Stop it.
Stop.
SIGGI: Perfect.
That rye, I mean,
it smells amazing.
I just-- Mmm.
May I just take a little slice?
Absolutely.
GORDON RAMSEY: Oh, my Lord.
Siggi, I'm in heaven.
SIGGI: Yeah.
Look at that.
GORDON RAMSEY: Oh.
Oh, my God.
I just want to dive in there.
This is beautiful.
SIGGI: And then--
GORDON RAMSEY: Oh.
Something quite special
about slicing warm bread.
And then on--
SIGGI: On top of the bread?
GORDON RAMSEY: Amazing.
SIGGI: Exactly.
GORDON RAMSEY: I mean,
this is the most glamorous
buffet in Iceland tonight.
Cheers.
Look at that.
Food fit for a Viking.
Yeah.
Come on.
Mmm, wow.
Goes well together, you know.
That is delicious.
Honestly, a marriage
made in a volcano.
It's rich, very dense.
It's sweet and salty as
well at the same time.
Yeah.
It's got me thinking
because this technique
with rye bread amazing.
Thank you.
Chef to chef, thank you, bud.
Very nice meeting you.
Take care.
You, too.
GORDON RAMSEY (VOICE OVER): That
was an extraordinary rye bread.
And Siggi was right.
Unlike one I've ever tasted.